hey everyone it's me derek from the
channel veritasium and i've been
following this series by Destin on
smarter every day about helicopters and
gyroscopic precession is just one of
those things that still blows my mind as
it did Destin so I'm here at the
University of Sydney my old stomping
grounds I'm gonna borrow some of their
lecture demmick Whitman to hopefully
teach you a bit about how gyroscopic
precession works the first thing I need
to do is talk about vectors because a
lot of things in physics are vectors
that means they have direction so an
example would be momentum and force
there's the two examples of some pretty
common vectors so if I have a cart
moving along here it has some momentum
in that direction and if I apply a force
to it I can change its momentum so for
example if I push it to the right then
its momentum will increase to the right
it all makes a lot of sense well there's
a similar statement we could make about
rotating bodies which is that a torque
increases the angular momentum of an
object in the direction of that torque
so let's try to figure out those terms
if I apply a force down on this side of
the wheel I create a torque and the
torque is Force Times the distance from
the rotating axis you could call it R so
torque is the force applied times the
radius away from the turning axis now
what's the direction of that torque well
we actually use a right hand rule to
define this and so what you do is you
put your fingers in the direction of the
radius from the turning axis and curl
them in the direction of the force and
your thumb points in the direction of
the torque so the torque is actually out
this way at 90 degrees to the force the
force is down that way but the torque
vector is actually pointing out this way
so the angular momentum of this wheel is
being increased in that direction so the
more I apply this torque the more I
increase the angular momentum of the
wheel in the direction of the torque so
I'm making this wheel have a very large
angular momentum out towards the camera
out towards you now before I go any
further let's have a look at this setup
that I've got I have a wheel here
hanging from only one side by this rope
and so right now there's actually a
torque on the whole system if I let go
because the weight of this wheel is
pulling down and that force is applied
at this distance away from it's pivoting
point there so if I let go well it does
exactly what you'd expect the wheel
swings down this way but I want to see
that as an example of rotational motion
there's a torque which is pointing out
this way which is trying to increase the
angular momentum of the system in that
direction now angular momentum in that
direction requires that the whole system
starts swinging anti-clockwise and so
that is what happens but what happens if
I only let go after I've already spun up
the bicycle wheel well in that case the
bicycle wheel would already have angular
momentum this way and so a torque
pushing that way actually swings this
angular momentum round that way okay so
let me try to get the wheel spinning and
make it work come on oh look at that
it's rotating as we predicted see the
angular momentum vector is pointing out
this way but torque is pushing it this
way so angular momentum torque and
torque is pushing that angular momentum
vector around except not for long
because this appears to be a quite
friction friction full wheel so check
out Destin's other videos about
helicopter physics and then come check
out my channel veritasium where you can
find more like this except I don't often
nearly get my head cut off by a bicycle
wheel